what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome
Destiny hey what's up thank you for
coming
thanks for having me how how was um your
experience on our show last night it was
so good do you really look at each other
when you do the show we can see each
other right there yeah I know I don't
know but I mean like if you want to do
this I mean yeah we could look forward
all right
so you enjoyed the show yeah I had a lot
of fun yeah it was that was the craziest
show we've ever had honestly
yeah I felt like I was back on fresh and
fit you know people getting kicked off
left and right it was crazy I was never
happy that's a crazy thing but today
guys I decided that me and Destiny are
gonna react to our time on the show
yesterday so pull the clip blessing
else wait can I can I do a thing on the
average thing real quick because we we
were talking about that for real oh
she's like gearing up did you see that I
didn't catch the she's like wait wait go
back for a second she's like getting
ready to go I want to see I want to see
can I do a thing on the average thing
real quick because we we were talking oh
oh my gosh she is think about that for
real fine okay because you can add off
to you one bit I was gonna say well it's
not my shirt so whatever yeah whatever's
alive okay so what the reason why when
somebody calls somebody average that's
usually perceived to be an insult right
I think we hear it that way we give it
that way nobody's ever told somebody
that there's their average is like a
nice thing to say to somebody now we can
say that like oh well average is most
people are average kind of but also not
really right if you look at like an
average person like an average person
has 1.9 legs because some people are
missing legs but no human has 1.9 legs
you have two or one right when we look
at who we are as people there are some
things that we excel at and there are
some things that we don't do anything
yet so I think that's why we never feel
average right because we're above
average hopefully at whatever our
competency is in do you think most
people are above average at something I
was thinking about this yesterday uh
first of all that guy is spitting for
real for real damn uh yeah I mean I
would assume most people are above
average or at least something I would
hope so right
I don't know most people will have like
an interest in something that you might
be as dumb as watching some reality TV
show or having some encyclopedic
knowledge of some random [__] video
game but I think most people are above
average at something you have to spend
your time in some way right sometimes I
feel like we're skewed because like the
people we're gonna be around are above
average at things I mean maybe not on
like shows like this but the people you
know in your actual personal life
you know
actually now are usually good at stuff
because like if you truly have a person
who is super average at everything with
no interest they would probably say as
much that'd be my guess
I don't know I don't know okay would you
say that somebody's average is always
going to be perceived as an insult so
I'm sure that uh Camilla or anybody else
you guys all had crazy degree you guys
are all more educated than I am right
I'm sure that on a whole you might be an
average person but you're not going to
perceive yourself that way because you
push yourself forward in some areas that
make you not average and hopefully
you're looking for other people to plug
into that those uh above average
it could be an average I just want to
say it's not about even my degree you
know it's not about my masters it's
about what I've overcome and achieved in
this life that makes me a Survivor and
above average I have been homeless on
the street and I'm sitting here today
and not representing that my struggle My
Success makes me above average and
nobody can't tell me that I'm not
because if that's what I need to tell
myself to get up in the morning and do
my [__] that's what's gonna have to
happen that's who will win okay
hold on bro now
you need a mute all button I think you
need like an e you know did you ever
watch uh the Chernobyl show you know
they had uh actually no I didn't I just
said yes oh there was a button you can
push to like pull out all the reactor
rods to make so that everything is okay
you need to mute all button you can push
which [__] is flying off the handle can
you hear that blessing do you hear that
no because I I'm not really a yeller so
sometimes when everyone's yelling I'm
just like I I don't know how to get them
to like be quiet but they just keep oh
my God
this should be more complicated to set
up if all these lights were plugged in
to a strip and then you had like a
second set of Lights plugged in that
were red LED lights that mute all button
you could push it and it would turn off
the main lights it would flood with the
red lights and everybody would be muted
you would get everybody to shut up super
fast do you know what I thought about I
was like what if we had super chats
where like 500 Super Chat we kicked
someone off the show you could do that
people would definitely pay four or five
hundred dollars they get their mic muted
for 30 minutes you'd have to a little
bit less but yeah people would do it
yeah what was the producer doing back
there he was milking it I was getting so
irritated I was like he was milking it
he knew there was a big clip about the
blob he didn't want you to [__] the
content that's what you're about to do
is that what you're doing blessing
we're gonna go viral
disrespectful
um
don't talk to me like that bro
stop stop stop stop
I just told you to stop talking guys
guys I was gonna give you a chance but
she she's on her story she's saying I
disrespected for her
disrespected her and I'm like how many
times did I say stop stop stop I would
have given her a chance to talk but I
was like lady
oh my good how many times did I tell her
I I didn't count if you're asking me you
want to go back at least three it was
quite a few times three you can't you
can't come on Wow 30 30 seconds ago 30
seconds and then you 30 seconds just
can't stop talking okay anyway I can't
remember she's just free real if I
remember okay
um it was just so funny like okay okay
guys guys
guys guys guys listen
listen listen guys guys
they might the mics are off now guys
guys guys guys guys
it feels like we're all coming in from
Recess
so we're all just screaming at each
other that's what it feels like what was
the girl
on the right Wright's name but if you're
sitting on the couch the left stage left
camera right is Fenty Fenty yeah look at
her face she's so funny she's just like
I am not associated
all right all right guys okay okay all
right thank you the first rule of the
podcast don't interrupt the horse what
was going through your head at this
point
um
I don't know I just thought it was
really funny I'm just I'm just here to
enjoy the ride I don't have any there I
just got into a big thing with um uh
like a z-list rapper guy who says he's
gonna kill me the next time I go to La
so it was reminding me of that actually
and I thought it'd be funny if I got why
for what uh because he's just very
fragile and then I see the same thing
happening here where people are like
very fragile when people start screaming
about like respect and disrespect the
feeling
okay I don't know this lady I wanna I'm
not okay let me I'm being broad it might
not apply to her but I feel like usually
when people are screaming like you're
disrespecting me you're disrespecting me
like that and they're getting really
crazy about it I feel like it's somebody
that doesn't commit a lot of respect
right like I'm talking to random person
they talk [__] about me I don't give a
[__] like my reputation everything like
speaks for myself like I don't need to I
don't need to throw down or start
getting crazier because why the [__]
would I care whatever but I feel like
when you have very little the in your
name and your respect it's like all you
have and people are way more willing to
like start screaming or maybe death
threats over it you know yeah because
that's so true because if you really
respect you don't have to scream like
yeah so I always say that when it comes
to like um like the false bravado people
like if I walk into a room and I'm in an
area where like people know who I am
like that's good enough for me I don't
have to like make a show but I feel like
some people feel like they really need
to advertise themselves constantly and
this like respect respect thing is like
part of that like if a guy goes into a
house and he's like this is my house it
is in fact not his house sure or there's
a oh [__] do you watch Game of Thrones
no God do you do anything no I don't
watch TV there's a line where an adult
says to his son and the son is mad and
he's like I am the king and then the
father says to the son no man that says
I am the king it's a true king or
whatever something like that right and
it's getting that point across right
yeah yeah we're not going to tolerate
that um if that happens you gotta go
thank you
yeah are you all cool with that okay all
right cool thank you I know and no
disrespect the stuff either thank you
okay I like that I like when he says do
you remember no homo no it's like when
somebody does something that's like a
little bit gay like no homework I like
how he's like no disrespect like that
would save him it's like the no
copyright infringement intended at the
start of it he's like no disrespect like
maybe that'll make her Comfort he's like
is that cool everyone
this room
it's like these two people are ready to
fight I think is that cool yeah
blessing where are you at with these
people it was Mel he was waiting for
that Viral moment
Instagram real ready to go oh my God
okay no no no no no stop okay thank you
I felt like I was talking to like a
two-year you do you have made your
substitute teacher I know I get this a
lot that I look like a teacher I'm like
and I'm like honestly with some of the
girls that come on the show I feel like
kids listen better yeah honestly like if
I tell a kid to stop so like they'll
stop but it's like
not not this late you you should you
should stand more when you talk to them
because you're very tall they're like 5
11 or something right yeah I'm like six
foot you're like five eleven I'm what
you're like five eleven this is what
guys always do you're five eleven you
could stand in Tower over these women
and intimidate them you know I'm six
foot guys always say that I'm shorter
than I am
um but yeah no I know people don't know
how tall I am yeah a lot there you go
you need to stand up when you tell
people to be quiet see if it works
better do you think it would work yeah
yeah you'd be like really intimidating
yeah do you think that would have been
intimidating to her yesterday I think
you're like yeah you're like the tallest
person here why not I think I would have
been yeah
um we're gonna go on to the next
question all right all right so I'm
gonna leave okay
this might be your platform but respect
okay okay goodbye go go go and this is
when she started to go off on me because
she wanted me to say like I'm sorry and
I'm like I'm not go fine the thing I
never understand in these situations and
I'm not trying to be arrogant or talk
[__] or whatever but it's like where is
like the leverage here right like who
are you right like if it was Andrew Tate
and he's like well I'm gonna leave and
it's like okay well hold on I don't want
Andrew Tate to leave my program right
but if you're just like a random person
it's like
I mean like what do you expect her to
say like oh my God I'm so sorry like
please I need you on my show like
there's like 25 other people in this
room right now you know yeah yeah I mean
I was just if she wants to go go I'll
see ya I really because she kept over
talking me before too and I was just
like
and I I feel like a lot of times the
girls on the show don't realize how much
they like and it's my fault too as a
host I need to work on like raining
people in but it's like it's hard I
don't know yeah okay because
catch a case up in his face
what does rebound mean here could
someone tell me yeah what does rebound
mean blessing yeah on the rebound oh
like I'll catch you later no it's like
taking bigger statement like yeah
wait wait did YouTube's more slang to
describe that's like what does check
your statement mean what not like taking
back a statement because I think she
said something like ah I'm just gonna
leave it but then I think that's when
she just went off on on King reaches
now this is the best part best words
and see that's the thing you get people
10 times matter if you laugh at them of
course yeah so I think that was when she
like really went off the rails because
he laughed at her yeah but again like
you gotta like understand
you're like does she really think she's
intimidating to him oh like if I got up
in front of the guy and I showed his
camera like he's not gonna be
intimidated by me he's not gonna be
intimidated by her like what are you
expecting to happen like I was like oh
my God I'm so sorry like I respect you
man like like forgive me like I'm with
you yeah I don't know I don't understand
yeah I don't understand what the thought
process is at all I mean this is the
thing I've learned I've had times on
this show where I've really tried to
rationalize things and like be like why
would they think like that and what I've
learned is that you just cannot
rationalize crazy
you cannot rationalize crazy behavior
you really can't wow
what
you know it's true
I'm supposed to rationalize this the
real you know what the reality is I'm
surprised God you're so just you don't
understand anything it drives me crazy
this is your moment you know what the
reality is here
is probably because
she's a woman
outside of this setting she probably
isn't used to ever having people like
push back against her that hard I that's
in my personal opinion I find that for a
lot of women they're not really used to
getting a lot of pushback and if they
get any they're expecting people to like
Buckle immediately and they're not
really expecting people to be like yeah
yeah and I think that that sometimes
like especially if one gets emotional
she expects other people to kind of like
bow to that but if that doesn't happen
then you get like increasingly unhinged
yeah I agree
she's right next to me no Auntie hates
it Auntie hates it
wow and what did she just say I'll hit
you on the rebound
Auntie's told you long time Auntie hates
it in the streets as well
and I'm gonna see how [__] out you are
cool yeah
okay
disrespect because I call everyone bro
don't call me bro I don't know you so
that's what you have to say that's what
we have to say you don't mind
so my moment here what I was thinking of
my head was
of course do they have the n-word in
London because I was waiting for her to
say it over and over because she was
really mad and then she started saying
mug and I was like is that like Mug mutt
is that like a racial slur or something
or I have no idea my brain might just be
you know what mug means blessing he's
just an inside it's just like idiot
that's I learned slag here too that's
for like hoe right yeah 403. yeah the
three yeah yeah 304 304 sorry they
called because I did a street interview
once and this girl attacked me and like
she called me a slag during that so I
learned I learned this I've been this is
twice once on a street interview this is
the first time on a show I was thinking
I was just in shock honestly I have
never been I've never said this like 10
times but I've never been in a situation
like that before I was also worried that
I was wondering if she was actually
going to start attacking people because
I would know what would happen there
either I was I was looking I was like
looking at the guys
[Laughter]
what am I gonna do well you're in the
best position to do something what do
you mean what am I gonna do well because
like the if the King Richard's guy hits
this woman she's gonna die I mean he
can't that's a lose-lose for him right
so he's in a really awkward position
there but you you can you can do that
you ever seen that movie
Scott Pilgrim no you've never seen
anything oh my God what do you do in
your free time I don't I don't watch TV
I just I play volleyball that's what I
do in my free time you don't have like
never mind okay yeah I know do you know
something right do you know something
about it excuse me excuse me excuse me
what's your name young lady what's your
name T do you know what I'm gonna do for
the first time ever I'm gonna [__]
follow you why
why was she so mad
okay okay look at look at look at look
at your your issue your issue stop
you're doing it again okay oh my God
oh
my God
yeah well I think Auntie was just trying
to get her out to be honest sure I
thought that for a second maybe I think
because it just could have escalated I
was like wow I know big thank you to
attit for getting her out of there if
that's what you're trying to yeah
because when she was over there Auntie
kept saying like let's go let's go let's
go my favorite or we'll get to it go
ahead wait wait have we got to your
favorite moment yet in all of this
what's my favorite moment do you have a
favorite moment in all of this I have a
favorite moment I actually did not enjoy
this at all oh I'm so sorry for you I
think my favorite moment was when she
finally left
okay my favorite moment is close it's
when she closed the door then came back
like that before because ever like this
is other than the the whale incident but
that was that was not in my like I don't
know this was just worse have you ever
been in like a dangerous situation like
that not really but I feel like
strangely more comfortable here like if
I was in Miami I'd be worried that she's
about to pull out a gun and start
blasting and stuff is gonna go real
crazy but she's not like we're in London
you guys have knives here she doesn't
seem like the knife type uh so I think
we were just everybody's just screaming
at each other and it was okay you know
also Big Ups over here to blessing
controlling the camera nice job yeah the
camera work on point he grabbed one of
these guys and he had that yeah he was
following it the whole time still
switching up the scenes following the
lady yeah
mug
yeah
[Music]
used to bro
get out get out get out get out get out
wait
how many bodies
get out get out
get get the [__] get the [__] out of my
apartment get out oh my God
oh my God she comes back for one more
[Laughter]
what was that elevator right like
what do you think they said to each
other I mean they probably just talked
about Michael yeah I think I don't
know well fun time I did not have fun I
I hope you enjoyed that I did not enjoy
it it was just another Wild Tuesday
night okay hold on can I just for my own
safety who are we allowed to call bro
I just want to know get the [__] out
lock the door blessing go lock the other
side that's what I was like we better
lock these doors I am not I'm not having
this girl come back I do last thing lock
the phone
yo the only reason was because she kept
interrupting me Jesus Christ
look it I don't oh my God
what can you go check just go go double
check go
no but okay
that has never had I've never had anyone
lock off or kicked out I think we're
watching the rest of the show or what do
we no I think it's gonna go to the next
kickoff oh yeah
a good difference yeah but she's saying
I was like two one show oh my God
yeah okay okay
guys guys guys guys guys guys guys okay
she's gonna be like waiting outside bro
I don't want to die in Life okay you
know it's crazy we're supposed
I swear we have security every other
panel this week except for today or
yesterday I was like how the one day we
didn't have it scary I'm sorry I'm I was
scared yeah the only reason I was gonna
let her talk is the crazy thing but she
kept interrupting me and I was just like
if you're gonna keep interrupting me you
have to go like the Nestor finds this
Outlet it's like a forewarn out
it's like it's like there's your warning
Esther
I don't think she could hear you
honestly and you didn't call her name as
well no she could she could hear she
could she just kept no she I give up wow
they're saying Esther's the same one I
like how you didn't give an excuse to
the Modern Woman
give an excuse oh yeah because he was
like maybe she didn't hear her no I mean
come on I'm Fair listen I'm nothing I'm
not fair when somebody's acting wild
okay I'll say they're acting Wild
I didn't think anyone was that crazy
until she started yeah okay my next
question
broke when I cool everyone broke it's
like it's just a respect thing it's like
you're Elders like I just would never I
didn't know yeah yeah it's just like I
just wouldn't call people that but I
don't think I don't think the Bro thing
didn't matter it was because they were
already heated I don't think anybody
cared really
um yeah I mean I I think it's like a
generational thing I could see like how
that would rub people the wrong like if
someone called my dad bro like they
would kind of rub him the wrong way but
he wouldn't
erupt an entire room and threaten to
grow you know I think that's not really
a I mean it depends too I'm guessing
because he probably if he's talking to
like an old person he's not gonna call
them bro that'd be my guess right
um
I don't think you meant it like that no
I I think they were already upset and
then him saying bro was just like a
Timber but they were cool and they were
calling each other
it doesn't matter
yeah and I think it's because you kept
antagonizing why did you have her move
but I'm getting crushed over here no you
have her move to the center no I didn't
tell her to do it she just did it I
didn't tell her I thought you could move
no she asked if she could I was like you
can I don't gotcha I'm pretty easy going
if you wanna if you want to squish it
it's not I don't call me brain you're
like all right bro
yeah
when I'm speaking like it's just my
vernacular that's just how I speak in it
like so I'm leaving thinking like oh
yeah I'm trying to push her buttons like
all my thing was is that let me say
something because at this point I've
said the least out of everybody a few
moments later uh I was gonna close out
the show so thank you guys all for
coming I didn't know we put in that edit
with the SpongeBob
hey we made it look who's left
I don't think I've been on a fresher
Style
[Laughter]
I can't believe
I'm so sorry I felt like I made it under
that
that was my bed it was your bad thank
you for acknowledging it it's basically
all your fault
I want to point out why you said TV you
said Africa is the best but Nigeria is
the best okay can you pause for a second
[Music]
night okay Nigeria is in Africa right am
I crazy
am I she said that and I thought for a
moment I was like am I [__]
I did
I've been so confused by that but okay
or we create blessings from Africa
[Laughter]
we're talking about
so I wanna I wanna literally can't
believe that happened I want to point
out no you said TV you said Africa is
the best but Nigeria is the best I'm
Nigerian oh I mean
I yeah I'm not sure I don't know I
didn't want to say anything because I
because then I started second guessing
like Nigeria is that like in the Middle
East is that South America is it my
[__] [__]
okay I didn't even catch that I was so
shy
I think she was ready why would you say
you want to go to South Africa so bad
because the top producers South African
no he's not
he's a blessing he's not from South
Africa wrong
that's the reason I mean I think
I don't know what's going on here okay
give me the white power in here
well I just said that because I just
felt like some type of way of the way
she she addressed the whole um Caribbean
you're African and I'm gonna speak like
I just kind of it just rubbed me the
wrong way like it's not that deep like
you know what I'm saying I don't really
understand why she left a lot to
Africans though they think now they're
better than Africans because they can
win right is that true blessing there's
like African
Caribbean drama
yeah I don't want a beef in Caribbeans
I'm okay
but there's a lot of tension in that
respect but I just feel like like
obviously I like bro at the end of the
day if you're really gonna take that as
like oh yeah I'm gonna leave I mean
that's up to you in it and I think and
and anyone watching anyone that's ever
watched a video with me will I do the
podcast with the girls I call everyone
bro everybody bro it's not now the um
especially being disrespectful to anyone
I don't think you I think I don't think
you meant it like that and I I don't
know we're just gonna you're so frazzled
but I think you should okay try and
listen to people though
[Laughter]
you need to listen you need to listen
Okay okay so we're gonna close out the
show so any final thoughts please 30
seconds or less
um and you can plug in your social media
where they can find you whatever so
starting here and then go around oh
final thoughts no can we go start on
this side I need to talk about it fine
um she didn't know how much time she was
gonna get to think about it
she might have set her up there maybe if
she went first there's like another
world where she gave her final thoughts
and Esther gave hers and everything was
fine or maybe it was the reverse order
here she set her up for failure Michael
do you want to start
all right we got to me
no listen King Richard's on YouTube go
check out my channel uh we got podcasts
over there over there we've got uh shows
podcasts reaction videos everything
um yeah go check out the channel and
what's my final thoughts uh
yeah maybe I should stop calling people
bro but you know it's just the way I
speak it's not I mean
oh
the stream day
I hear your dog snoring
you guys have any questions for Destiny
put them in the chat I'll ask him while
we're waiting
get ready for the Ester count
um you should never call Russ says he
should never call women bro
it's like
you got it
okay cool
okay
good luck on the streets tonight yeah
yeah
well done I'm proud of you thank you
okay Destiny yeah uh Big Ups to Pearl
for hosting this great show uh you can
find me at youtube.com Destiny that's
all I got
um Pearl stop saying Esther you need to
listen
yeah
it's disrespectful to not to over talk a
host on someone else oh purple I'm
talking I'm talking you need to listen
because you talk I'm talking it's my
time it's my time to talk how does that
feel you talk the whole Esther how does
that feel okay
okay
I'll give you no time I'm gonna give you
no time all right your turn go go your
turn your turn okay then I like it you
expect the girl next year to go well
she's just screaming her I'm Fenty I
feel like
I see where this teacher thing comes
from I've always wondered like why does
everyone say I look like a teacher I'm
like I don't know if it's an insult or
what but I kind of see it because this
does give me like teacher but like no
like okay next I don't know the fur
kitten else wait can I can I do a thing
on the average thing real quick because
we
let's see how we get there
here get out of my get out of my
apartment get I always go a little bit
further
looking
because
I'm looking rude I can't get in get out
I like how she's yelling at me and I'm
perfectly calm I'm just like Esther
Esther and I'm the one being disrespect
it's like I'm saying your name you're
the one you
it's like these crazy women
I can't say Esther Esther Esther get
Esther Esther get out after then go
Esther get out get out of my get out of
my apartment get out no get out no get
out get out I'm not gonna do that
anywhoes faster no your mic is muted get
the [__] out of my apartment get out get
out you're gonna be disrespectful the
whole goddamn show get out yeah I'll
call security I'll literally call
security that's very rude no can you
call security no no because you are
being rude because you are over talking
me call security get her out
laughs
anyway
I'm going to be doing a lot more podcast
and political uh Media stuff this is
smart on her like bro get on the end of
the barrel clip right there she knew the
viral
and yeah I hope to I this is a lot of
fun and yeah can't wait to do more
nice amount
it's like the world's longest silence
like I swear to God
wait I was like I will sit here and keep
this live until the security guard comes
I do not care
because it's not fair I'm so sorry you
don't invite me into your house and then
try to disrespect me by kicking me out I
am sorry I'm gonna have my voice
security we're all gonna talk because
we're not gonna do that that is very
disrespectful I like how she thinks
she's gonna talk to security it's like
if if you're in my apartment yeah and I
own like I pay you at the apartment I
don't want you in it there's no talking
you just have to leave yeah like what's
that
I don't know how she thought that was
gonna go you can you can put her no
that's the ultimate disrespect how dare
you invite me to your husband and they
tried to kick me out because I'm trying
to tell you how I felt about how you're
treating me you're just embarrassing
yourself embarrassing myself
but can I just say one last time ah
listen she's a champion for trying yeah
a for effort maybe I wonder what this
last insightful thing is going to be
we'll never know you ruined it
hey headphones headphones
that was so smart plugging the Instagram
in there yeah
okay faces are so funny I'm just waiting
to see who goes next you know
foreign
so just know what it is and yeah go
subscribe to my channel bro yeah this
happens a lot on my channel as well yeah
even more so go subscribe King riches
right now yeah go subscribe to my
Channel right now yeah if you like drama
like this go subscribe to my Channel
right now I feel like I won The Hunger
Games
yeah well hold on we just said that with
four of us here okay
I'm the last standing girl you know it's
crazy this is I swear to God this has
never happened in my year of shows
anyways
um okay guys it was a lot of fun I loved
it okay guys um thank you for watching
this this [__]
shows Matt
um this is your first show coming back
yeah thank you for watching this show we
love this city thank you to Destiny for
coming on yes
enjoying this you know
um thank you guys for coming I
appreciate it I appreciate being able to
have these conversations guys make sure
you like the video I'd say respectfully
disagree but someone threatened me yeah
like I can't even say that um okay like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel also um guys follow my
Instagram just pearly things one
nice why is your first Instagram get
banned or did it get unbanned
okay so it got banned because
for me and this girl is calling me ugly
and I just feel like if you call me ugly
I can call you a whale okay if you start
it so she had on her story like
something saying that my face like
something you know ugly whatever and so
I just shared it and put it on my story
and because she was a bigger lady and my
bigger lady I'm talking like 250 plus
three like she was a big woman and so I
just put who would you rather smash I
was just curious putting a poll out
there you know just to get some feedback
right and and it's not my fault how the
polls turned out so then I shared the
poll and I just put the whale emoji and
an alert and again she started it had
she not called me ugly first I would not
have responded okay no yeah Instagram
did not take that into account so yeah
so
um
I'm trying to think so the guy is coming
at like 7 30. so how long do you want to
get how long do you want to react for
because we can either close it or we can
react to one more thing it's up to you I
probably want to go get something to eat
I'm ready okay
um guys tune in at what are we doing
eight o'clock is that what it's
scheduled for
8 30. okay so 8 30 guys um on the
channel tonight Destiny is going to be
debating on Tate
um like the video on your way out thank
you for coming thanks for having me here
well they're asking can you address uh a
last statement in the in the lobby okay
okay
can we can we show the thing in the
lobby room
okay just so the part
um just the part that Destiny said can
you cut it yeah yeah just because I
think it's like a 10 minute rant we
don't need to alive
oh you're renaming it from the pregame
did I see that yeah um was thinking I
need to keep everything more consistent
like with pearl in it I feel like it's
kind of random is your name actually
Pearl it's my middle name
wait did you say your first name yeah my
first name's Hannah okay but it was like
a nickname it started in college because
there's another Hannah on the volleyball
team so people just called me Pearl well
I mean it's kind of a nickname but it's
also like your middle name yeah yeah and
so I was thinking that it should like
like everything should be consistent in
a way on the channel and when I started
the pregame it was because we were all
athletes and like because I played and
play Semi-Pro volleyball here but now
it's like what do you what are you
thinking of for instead of the pregame
then I was thinking Pearl talk okay the
Pearl talk show talk okay but I'm open
to suggestions anyone can put it in the
chat or if you think of anywhere
okay I stopped playing
I'm so sorry
oh you guys are still here you okay yeah
come you guys come and say something
Destiny is always defending me I'm not
no I don't I shouldn't you relentlessly
I hate you I don't like you I hate what
you talk about I hate your talking
points you hate me oh my gosh I hate you
I hate you why do you you why are you
always defending me
for someone that hates me I just get
caught in situations where I
unfortunately have to take his side on
your favorites but it happens by chance
every time okay every every time yeah
yeah but I I think he actually secretly
likes me because literally he's always
defending me someone will teach her a
lesson I feel like someone needs to
teach her a lesson is that a threat
she means rhetorically I'm sure
uh yeah she still means that it's
metaphorically
I mean did you talk about a plan yeah to
come on your show and rhetorically
one-up you Rev [__] out of order
I I'm out of or okay I'm so sorry
oh you guys are still here you okay yeah
come can you guys come and say something
can you talk about what happened in
there it was crazy child can you guys
see your honest feedback as to what
happened in that do you think she really
wanted your honest feedback no probably
not but what am I what do you want me to
say damn
I had a lot of fun it was hilarious
then yeah me again kicked off please can
you comment on that because I'm actually
female do I have a right to be annoyed
I think the biggest problems when the
host is talking if you keep coming over
the show kind of like descends into
chaos
she was running into
yeah the look she was giving me right
here
I'm so sorry she seems like a cool
person no problem but she was definitely
expecting me to bag her there and she
was giving me the big I could tell that
the computer had to process for like
three seconds like what I just said I
felt really bad
why did you feel bad
it's like it's like now I feel like I'm
just bullying her with you I'm not I'm
not bullying I feel like a bully I feel
like a Bully Now were you not bullying
me when you said you hated me yeah you
deserve to be bullied why do I deserve
to be bullied because you're tall I I'm
very
yeah that's right you know it yeah go
ahead just me talking about
that's what you're doing a podcast you
speak she starts yelling at you she's
like can I have your honest feedback he
gives his honest feedback but but that's
what you do on a podcast
left
yeah
I was quiet for quite a bit Yeah he was
talking a lot but she wasn't talking to
over people I think that the main issue
is that this would be my advice for
shows is that a lot of people I feel bad
because the King Richard's guy he was
sitting there quiet for a lot of the
show so when she was like oh he was
talking to everybody was like nah that
guy like there was like a solid like 20
minutes where I don't think he said a
word yeah no he's talking he gotta chill
because we talk about those too much
that'll get you kicked off almost
anything I think that's usually what
people so even if you see a lot of
people talking over each other when the
host starts talking you gotta chill
otherwise yeah I think she gets [__]
that's just what I've seen after this
one
you know what's funny what happened with
her on the show before well she okay
you're always funny she went on a
different show with this other girl that
I would always bicker with too and she
it was like a similar thing where she
thought the other girl would take her
side with her name's denelva and she did
it she like comes up do you think I was
in the wrong of that situation I think
so just because of other girls
her house is a certain sometimes she she
does have the right to talk over because
she's the host no I'm gonna say it no no
I don't know what you were saying about
it but my point is I just said I just
said Pearl you need to stop saying
things like well you need to learn to
listen that that is very patronizing it
is but it is her shoe so because it's
her show she can be disrespectful to
people
is that how you guys think she thinks I
think there was another way to go about
it rather than to turn into it how how
can I have gone I literally said it in a
nice way
oh man
did she did she go about it
I mean uh no I'd say probably not please
can we stop saying oh Esther you don't
listen
[Music]
it was just it was very messy
but I think you hear problems with the
husband the best way to bring it up is
afterwards yeah yeah but we've tried on
the show the house is always going to
win
um I mean she
would you say that trying to talk to me
outside of the podcast is going on
another podcast and calling me racist
and sexist no I meant like after the
show like talking no I met her she said
she tried to you oh I don't I don't know
you guys think just because she's the
host she can be disrespectful to people
no in a way yeah well no no yeah she can
be and at that point you either leave or
you yeah yeah because they're you're
like in their Kingdom it's like their
world you know you know what it is
because you know what Poe is are you
guys listening to this because you are
the host of a podcast you can be
disrespectful to people sorry when does
that make sense makes sense that's how
it's like it's like if you're in
somebody else's house they could be
disrespected to you it's like what's
that word you're not gonna oh yeah your
boss at work yeah if you're going to
somebody else's house and they're like I
don't want you
need to show I wasn't being dishes
welcome to her I just said Pearl please
can you stop doing this whole
um you need to learn to listen it's
quite patronizing that's all I said what
was that being did she sell for yeah
they're trying to talk over her
yeah because she's trying to get me to
Bender like change it so that I can
agree but like
oh this is her shoe also it's okay to me
and I'm supposed to stay there
well anyway say bye to everyone Hi
what's the trench coat for there's a lot
of people talking about the trench coat
and I didn't know that's iconic I didn't
understand it's like a movie or
something uh yeah the movie of my life
okay when they do a biography of me it's
gonna be starring that trench coat oh I
just like the color blue a lot I don't
know if you could tell
yeah I thought they I saw something on
YouTube that it was like from a movie or
something no no okay
okay well all right that's pretty much
it wow but yeah um you know thanks for
enduring that with me yeah no problem
and defending me as usual
um you really got my back I was
defending the concept of hosting in
general you just happen to be the host
and Destiny really has my back not at
all he has my back all the time okay
we'll see how you feel tonight okay when
you're the when you're the moderator
okay the hate videos that come Destiny
really seems to take my side yeah
anyways thank you for coming guys like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and go subscribe to
Destiny's Channel too youtube.com
Destiny instagram.com Destiny yeah yeah
he has a really pop in like chat too on
his website thanks uh like the video on
your way out and I'll talk to you next
time oh